[Music]
this wasn't a John right no as for you
is for your it's for your ass so it has
a stopper on it and then you put the
whole front under somebody's behind ya
cuz it's not like a vagina it doesn't
get wet like that and I personally like
this when I'm masturbating or during sex
as well it's the extra stimulation so
why somebody playing with the front you
like that coming through
no it just go in there and just a you
just like it in you lock it in why
somebody playing with your front paws
that's that's a lot of stimulation what
else do you like on here what's another
one of your favorites this one are for
your pelvic floor exercises a vagina is
just like a muscle the more you work it
out the stronger it gets put it in this
way you put it in that way and this is
to pull it out like no like its HAMP on
ladies
and yeah you insert it and then you know
you just go you know straighten up your
room do your dishes go for a job yeah go
for a little jog come back and it's like
you Watson no clutching it achieving it
okay ladies it's important to have that
muscle that pajama muscle ladies it's
good to have that that muscle control
well I found that kegels make me want to
throw up so kegels is like like I'm
doing it right now
well you just like kind of going like
this you can't make a nauseous if I do
too many so I like to just insert this
and then kind of just go about your
business
yeah just maybe like 15 to 20 minutes a
day you know it's like a little workout
for your insides and then it just keeps
it like nice and tight you do know this
is gonna go superpower right this
like the troll alone